cancer causing chemicals in sunscreen  it's a major reason one online pharmacy  wants the fda to recall some popular  products  valisher pharmacy that's the online  pharmacy it says it's worried about  chemicals like benzene being found in  nearly a third of lotions and sprays by  neutrogena banana boat and cvs products  medical experts say the fda will look at  how the chemicals are getting into those  products  there's no manufacturer that's  intentionally adding it  to the sunscreen product somehow it's in  there as a contaminant it's not clear  how it gets in there  is it one of the ingredients that got  contaminated is it the process of making  the lotion or the after sun product that  somehow creates it we're not sure  now not all the products from those  brands were found to contain benzene  and health experts emphasize most  sunscreens do not contain that chemical  and you have to protect yourself from  the sun